DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Hello,
I'm Dustin Kirkland,
a product manager at Google.
I'm here with Tim Hockin, tech
lead for the Kubernetes project
at Google.
Tim, you've been around
Kubernetes since the beginning.
You've seen the
past, the present,
and maybe have some
ideas about the future.
Walk us through the
past, present, and future
of Kubernetes.
TIM HOCKIN: Sure.
So know Kubernetes was
born at Google, obviously.
It took a lot of
ideas from Google,
but it is not exclusively
a Google thing.
This community is an amazing
thing that has happened.
The past, you know,
we've spent five years
building this system.
We're here now with
8,000 of my best friends
talking about Kubernetes.
It's amazing to
have gotten here.
Five years ago, I
would never have
believed that we would be here
in Spain talking about this.
Here we are today, we're
still working in Kubernetes.
It is still maturing.
It is servicing way
more than we initially
thought we would possibly
be able to address, more use
cases, more users, more scale.
And future-- you know,
it's still growing.
We're still doing more.
We're tackling new
use cases every day.
We've got customers and
users here all the time
talking about this new use
case, this new problem,
and so I'm excited to see
how much more we're going
to grow and tackle what's new.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND:
And Google is one
of the leaders in the Kubernetes
project, but not the only one.
There's a lot of
vendors involved
in and around Kubernetes
and other projects.
How do you see the
role of vendors
in and around the
Kubernetes community?
TIM HOCKIN: I'm one of the
tech leads of the project.
I work on a lot of different
areas within the project,
obviously, and I
oversee a lot of work.
And I work at
Google, and you might
think that would be conflicting,
but I think it's not, really.
The leads of the project
are very much fanatical
about being vendor
neutral, about being open,
about being very transparent.
The project is set up in a
way that everything we do
can be seen by anybody who
wants to pay attention.
And I think that
shows in the quality
of the code, the quality
and number of contributors,
where they're coming from.
We have contributors from
every time zone on the planet,
from almost every continent.
I still haven't proved whether
we have someone in Antarctica
or not.
If you're in Antarctica
and you're contributing
to Kubernetes, call me.
This has been a
really important part.
The vendors are a critical
piece of our ecosystem.
Kubernetes would
not be successful
without the ecosystem.
We knew this from
the beginning, and I
am happy to say that we're
really successful there.
But it is still a
community-driven project
that is not tied or locked
in to any one vendor.
While we have a ton
of people at Google
who are working on
Kubernetes, myself included,
they are not exclusively
focusing on Google's work.
They're working to build
the project at large.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: And
you've got a lot of insight
with a lot of customers,
a lot of users,
and a lot of community members
working with Kubernetes.
What are some of the
trends you see emerging,
maybe some unexpected trends
or patterns you've seen emerge?
TIM HOCKIN: So, I do.
I talk to a lot of customers,
and I've definitely
seen some emerging trends.
We've passed the
point where people
are struggling to figure
out if they need Kubernetes.
It's more or less assumed now
if you're building big systems,
Kubernetes is the way to do it.
But the patterns that are
emerging now are scale--
large size.
How big can my clusters get?
How many pods can
I run on a node?
What's the density
that I can achieve?
How do I drive my utilization?
We're talking about
multi-cluster situations.
I've got clusters around the
world, around the country--
how do I link them together
and make them work together?
Some of these
problems are sort of
at the very edges of
Kubernetes itself,
but I think there's a lot we
can do within Kubernetes to make
it easier to build
solutions that
are solving these problems.
Hybrid is a really
hot topic right now.
The reality of, you know, people
are stuck in other clouds,
or they're stuck on-premises,
and there are really
good reasons for
that, and they're
trying to find ways to
work across these different
environments.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Tim,
thank you very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]